استنادا الى وثائق تقول صحيفه الواشنطن
انها حصلت عليها الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ارسال قاعده عسكريه العائمه الى
منطقه الخليج واسباب ارسال ها هي تزايد
التوتر مع ايران يهدد باغلاق مضيق هرمز
تصاعد المعارك في اليمن
حياكم الله نتوقف مع هذا الخبر لنناقشه في
عنوانين رئيسيين ما موقع هذا السيناريو في
اطار الاستراتيجيه العسكريه الجديده
لواشنطن وما هو الشكل وردود الافعال
والتداعيات التي يمكن ان تثيرها
اذا بحسب التسريبات ثم هذه السفينه الام
واعدها لتتحول الى قاعده عسكريه عائمه
تسمح استعدادا لارسالها الى الشرق الاوسط
بتوجه بعض من قواتها المرابطه في مياه
الشرق الاوسط تكون القوات البحريه
الامريكيه قد عادت في نظر متابعيها الى
بيئتها الطبيعيه بعد سنوات قاسيه قضتها في
يابسه العراق وافغانستان
افرض ايران نفسها محطه رئيسيه في اهتمامات
الجهد العسكري الامريكي
فهي المتهمه بنفوذ تستثمره في ساحات
العراق وافغانستان
وهي ايضا صاحبه المشروع النووي المثير
التسلح المستهدفه بعقوبات غربيه جعلت
طهران تلوح بغلق مضيق هرمز الممر
الاستراتيجي العالمي للنفط ليس في المنطقه
ايران فقط القاعده التي فقدت زعيمها بن
لادن تحاول استرداد الانفاس في بلدان مثل
اليمن فردوس الانفلات الامني والسياسي
المغرب لكل من دين انه الخروج على الحكام
الموالين في نظره الغرب وامريكا
ما دامت الاهتمامات المفترضه للسفينه
الامن قد وصلت الى تلك الاصقاع نظر لو
انها ت طلعت الى القرن الافريقي حيث
الجماعات المواليه للقاعده في الصومال و
اعمال قرصنه نقصت على الملاحه الدوليه
نشاطها في مضيق عدم مضيق يجاوره شرق اوسط
سيستقبل ولاشك السفينه ال ام اذا هي ولدت
مياه بمعدل ته التاريخيه ممثله في الصراع
الفلسطيني الاسرائيلي غير بعيد عن جنوب
لبنان الذي ينام ويصحو على هدنه هشه بين
الجيش الاسرائيلي وحزب الله قد تنهار ذات
منعطف ما الى الشرق سوريا وما ادراك من
سوريا المقبله على المجهول مع اشتداد موجه
الاحتجاجات المطالبه برحيل نظام الاسد من
يتطلع الى سوريا يصعب عليه ان يتجاهل
العراق بلاد الرافدين التي تخشى عوده
الحرب الطائفيه الطاحنه بسبب اعمال العنف
التي تتجدد بين حين واخر
يعلم المريض على الارجح ان سفينتهم
القديمه الجديده ان تشق عباب المتوسط
والخليج برحله سياحيه لكنها ستكون على اي
حال شاهده من موقعها العسكري على نجاح او
فشل استراتيجيه اوباما العسكريه وغير
العسكريه الراميه الى نفس الايه وان تغيرت
الزبير الحاق الهزيمه باعداء البيت الابيض
عبر العالم
لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من واشنطن
ريتشارد
مدير مركز التحليلات السياسيه والعسكريه
في معهد هدف من دبي معنا الدكتور مصطفى
العاني مدير قسم الابحاث الامنيه
والدفاعيه في مركز الخليج للابحاث اهلا
بكما وابدا معك
سفينه عمرها اكثر من اربعه عقود كانت على
وشك ان تحال للتقاعد البنتاغون يعجل من
امرها في اعاده تاهيلها حتى تصبح جاهزه في
الصيف حتى انه يتجاوز بعض الاجراءات
البروتوكوليه ماذا نقرا في هذا
في الحقيقه يقول انه لا يسرع بارسال هذه
السفينه لتشارك في ايه عمليات قتاليه
وسواء صدقنا هذا اولا هذا ما يقولونه على
ايه حال لكن من جهه اخرى هناك مسار طويل
المدى مثل هذا النوع من السفر التي يمكن
ان تخدم دورها من دون ان تلعب دورا وثانيا
بحد ذاته لكن تمكن لزوار اصغر حجما من ان
تتوغل في المناطق المحيطه بها
عمليات معينه
ونعلم ان
هددوا ولم المح الى احتمال غرق مضيق هرمز
فيما لو ان الولايات المتحده وحلفاءها فرض
عقوبات ال معينه او اتخاذ الاجراءات
الاخرى واحدى السبل في عمل ذلك هو في زرع
الالغام في الماضي او ان يبعثوا في زوارق
صغيره مزوده بصواريخ
وبدات وما الى ذلك وكل على هذا ال
كالولايات المتحده ان تبعث حامله طائرات
عملاقه ولكن على ايه حال من المفيد ان
يكون في حوزه سفينه اصغر حجما تستطيع ان
تخدم كالقاعده تنطلق منها وحدات الالغام
او للقيام العمليات القتاليه
اعتقد ان هذا هو الاطار الذي يتحدثون عنه
فهو ربما ال ال ال لا اعتقد اصلا ايران
ستغلق المضيق لكن هذه ربما وسيله من
الوسائل
التي تحول دون ذلك اذن دكتور الوصف العالم
هي رساله سياسيه لايران يعني حتى اذا
فكرتم ان تغلقوا مضيق هرمز ف اننا مستعدون
لنرفع حتى لو كان خرده عسكريه تحسبا لاي
طارئ هل هذا ما نحن
الحقيقه ليست قضيه الخرده هذه السفينه
سيعاد
فيها
وهي مرحليه فقط ال الاستراتيجيه الجديده
رصدت مبلغ كبير لبناء قاعده قائمه جديده
نحن نتكلم عن ثلاثه سنوات فقط هذه السفينه
ستقوم بهذه الخدمه بعد ثلاثه سنوات ستدخل
اه قاعده جديده بنيت لهذا الغرض فنحن
نتكلم عن سياسه مستمره وليست اه اه اه اه
رد فعل لما يحدث الان هذه القاعده العامه
لها اسبابها اولا انه خلال السنتين
الماضيتين حاولت واشنطن الحصول على اذن من
احد دول من دول المنطقه بانشاء قائد
القوات الخاصه رفضت جميع الدول ما اعطي ل
واشنطن هو تسهيلات وليس قاعده واشنطن
تسهيلات طلبه قاعده ثابته حتى استطيع ان
تسمع فيها لها اسبابها هذه مهم جدا انه
نفهم انه جاءت من ال ال اه الاطار ال اه
الاستراتيجيه الجديده استراتيجيه جديده اه
قالت شيء شيء مهم جدا ان هناك تغيير في
مصدر التهديد وفي اه طبيعه التهديد
الاساسيه مصدر التهديد وطبيعه التهديد
والقوات الخاصه في اعطيت مجال خاص واهميه
خاصه اولويه خاصه في الميزانيه الجديده
وفي استراتيجيه الجديده لهذا السبب جاء
هذا القرار بوضع هذه ال ال ال القاعده
العائمه الى ان يتم انشاء قاعده ثابته
والقوات الخاصه مهمه جدا في في عمليات
المنطقه الان القوات
تقصد المعروفه والتي كان لها دور في
الاطاحه باسامه بن لادن وكذلك بقضيه ال
الم الرهائن الامريكيه والدانماركيه في
الصومال
بدون شك الحرب الان الى دائره ليس فيها
حرب عسكريه هي حرب مخابراتيه هي حرب
مجموعه تعتمد على على المعلومه الدقيقه
وتقوم اما القوات الخاصه بعمليه المداهمه
مثل ما قامت في الصومال وقامت في في اه اه
بالعراق عدد من العمليات كبيره وما قامت
في باكستان وافغانستان
والشيء الاخر هي قضيه الطائرات بدون طيار
طبيعه التهديدات فيحتاج انه تغيير رؤيه
الاستراتيجيه التسلح انا باعتقادي ان
الولايات المتحده تشعر بضروره كبيره لهذه
القاعده
والعمليات الخاصه ستكون لها مستقبل كبير
في المنطقه في مكافحه الارهاب وفي قضيه
مكافات القرصنه ومنع اغلاق مضيق هرمز هذه
القضيه مهمه انه هذه القطعه البحريه ستكون
لها مهمه اساسيه هي منع عمليه اغلاق
السيد
البعض يذهب الى ان هذه
القطعه كما سماها البحريه العائمه في
النهايه سيكون لها دور
وسيكون هناك ما ينذر بطيف ساخن هل توافق
ام
النظره العامه التي يقدمها ان تظل دائما
تقوم على اساس اننا يجب ان نستعد للحرب
لكي لا تكون هناك حرب لكن مع ذلك هناك
كلام من ايران حول التهديد باغلاق مضيق
هرمز حتى لو كان ذلك من باب ال الاساءه
للنفس لانهم يعلمون انه حتى لا خوف انه في
بعض الوقت في الولايات المتحده سوف تفتح
مره اخرى وبذلك تكون قد دمرت معظم القدرات
البحريه الايرانيه
لذلك هي تحاول اي ايران اخافه بعض البلدان
وفرض عقوبات
عليها وايضا هذه التهديدات تؤدي الى رفع
اسعار النفط تزيد من دخل ايران وايضا
تحاول بث بعض الشكوك حول قدره الولايات
المتحده وحلفائها وميلهم الى
التصعيد ربما الامر له علاقه بالوضع
السياسي الداخلي في رغم انه وضع
متناحره اخرى وخلافات بين رئيس الجمهوريه
والمرشد الاعلى للثوره وربما كل هذا اله
علاقه بما يدور في داخل ايران
الاشاره التي اثارها الدكتور مصطفى العاني
الى استخدام قوات
هذه القوات المتقدمه في مجال التدريب هل
تتوقع ان يكون لها دور مثلا في عمليات
سريه داخل ايران ايضا
هذا السؤال
ربما قد يفعلون ذلك على سبيل المثال
يمكنني ان اتذكر تلك الطائره من دون طيار
التي استولت عليها ايران
وربما لو كانت هناك وحدات من السيد هؤلاء
من القوات الخاصه البحريه ربما كانوا س
يستخدمون لاستعاده الطائره على سبيل
المثال لكن لو انهم كانوا هناك موجودين في
المنطقه ربما ستوكل اليه مهمه تسعه
الالغام و اخلاء المنطقه من
الالغام
والقيام بعمليات مضاده للالغام يمكن ايضا
ان يستخدم ضد القراصنه وقد تم حتى الان
اعتمدت عمليتان لانقاذ الرهائن والتحضير
الرهائن المره كان هناك انقاذ
الرهائن الايرانيين ومره اخرى للسويديين
وجنسيات اخرى فهؤلاء واحده
هؤلاء قادرون على القيام بهذه العمليات
الكفاءه فلنقل لو ان ايران اخذت ربما س
يستخدمون لتحريرهم لكن على الاعم الاغلب
سيكون الغرض من وجودهم هو الحيلوله دون
القيام بعمليات من حيث لا تضطر ايران للرد
الانتقامي عليها اريد ان اعود للدكتور
مصطفى العاني في نقطه ربما اشرت اليها
دكتور قلت ان هذه تتيح نوع من الاستقلاليه
ربما الولايات المتحده كون القواعد
العسكريه الموجوده اصلا
تخضع في النهايه لنفوذ الدول وهذه الدول
تسمح بتسهيلات لا اكثر ولا اقل بمعنى ان
هذه القاعده العائمه ربما تعطي الولايات
المتحده ال القدر الكافي من الاستقلاليه
لتقوم بما تريدون ان تشرك اخرين ودون حتى
ربما ان تخرج بعض حلفائها في المنطقه
كانت مشكله لقضيه حقوق السياده في باكستان
وفي اليمن وفي المناطق الاخرى انه استخدمت
الولايات المتحده بحقوق السياده ان هذه
الدوله لها حقوق سياسيه لها علاقات جيده
مع الدول الاخرى تحاول المحافظه عليها ولا
تسمح القوات الامريكيه ان تقوم بعمليه
اغتيال وتصفيات وعمليات هجوم على مواقع
محدده قال القاعده ستمنح الولايات المتحده
حريه كبيره في اه في القيام بعمليات لم
تتمكن القيام بها بسبب القيود التي فرضت
على الولايات المتحده او قوات القوات
الخاصه الامريكيه امريكا الان تمتلك قوات
خاصه في جيبوتي اريتيريا
وفي اه وفي باكستان وافغانستان
لكن نحن نتكلم عن منطقتنا هي المنطقه ال
الان التي تستجيب تواجد هذه القوات هناك
مشكله في اليمن هناك مشكله في الصومال
هناك مشكله في مضيق هرمز وحددت ال ال ال
ال الاستراتيجيه الجديده اشارت الى اه اه
مشاكل قد
تنتج عن الربيع العربي ان هناك قتل
التجمعات الكبيره امنيه في المنطقه نتيجه
للربيع العربي فالاستراتيجيه الجديده حدث
بجانب الارهاب بالجانب الجريمه المنظمه
وهي نتكلم هنا عن القرصنه بجانب تحدي
ايران هناك مشاكل الربيع العربي التي قد
تحتاج الى تدخلات سريعه الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه
العمليات التي يتبناها الرئيس اوباما
تختلف تماما عن الاستراتيجيه التي يتبناها
الرئيس بوش الرئيس بوش كان يعتمد على دخول
القوات على القوات الارضيه على قوات
المرينز الرئيس بوش او ما ما اكتشاف جديد
انه اه هناك ثمن سياسي قليل من ماده قليل
في نفس الوقت ان هذه القوات الخاصه تستطيع
ان تنجز اهداف لا تستطيع القوات الامريكيه
الثابته انجازها هذا بدون بدون اثاره
الدول هذه هذه القاعده ستكون عائمه في
المياه الدوليه وبالمناسبه ليست هي كبيره
نحن نتكلم عن سفينه مائه وسبعين مترا كانت
قدرتها الاستيعابيه خمسمائه جندي فقط فنحن
نتكلم عن القوه من قوات النخبه ستقوم
بعمليات التدخل ال ال الاختياري الانتقائي
في دول المنطقه بغض النظر عن رفض هذه
الدول او موافقتها او التحفظ على اساس
قضايا سياده اوباما يتجه الى اتجاه
واضح انه هو لا يعير لقضيه السياده اهتمام
يجب التذكير انه اوباما قام بعمليات في
داخل باكستان خلال سنه واحده اكثر من ما
قام به خلال ثمانيه سنوات وقام بعمليات في
اليمن اكثر من مقام بوش في خلاف ثمان
سنوات في سنه او سنتين فقط اوباما مستعد
للتدخل ولكن للتدخل على قاعده بغرام على
قاعده امر ظهر وهذه
سنه انتخابيه مثل هذه هذا ربما جزء او او
او واحد من الاسئله التي سنطرحها بعد
الفاصل كيف سيتم التعامل اقليميا مع وجود
مثل هذا قائمه هل هو مؤشر على عمل عسكري
والشيء في المنطقه نناقش ذلك بعد فاصل
قصير
اهلا بكم من جديد الى حلقتنا التي تتناول
وثائق تقول صحيفه الواشنطن الفوز انها
حصلت عليها تكشف نيه الولايات المتحده
ارسال قاعده عسكريه عائمه الى منطقه
الخليج
اريد ان نعود الى موضوع وجود هذه القاء
القاعده في المنطقه بغض النظر عن ما تعلنه
الولايات المتحده من نيتها الحقيقيه وراء
ارسال هذه القاعده في النهايه لا بد ان
يكون هناك ردود فعل في المنطقه ايران
تحديدا
كيف تتوقع ان ترد
اه الامر ان
هذه ان هذه السفينه لم تصل قبل بضعه اشهر
على ايه حال لكن ربما هناك امل من ان
الاعلام عن ارسال السفينه سيكون بعدا اخر
على ايران للحيلوله دون اقدامها على اغلاق
مضيق فان ايران نفسها ربما
هم لديهم
اسلوب ابتكار داعي في التعامل مع الحروب
والحرس الثوري لديه قوات خاصه تابعه له
قوات بحريه يطوروا تكتيكات عسكريه
وبامكانهم ان يستطيعوا اعاقه الملاحه
البحريه واغلاق المضيف من خلال ارسال
زوارق صغيره مسلحه خاصه بهم اذن ربما هم
يشعرون بالراحه اكثر بحشد وحدات صغيره او
زوارق صغيره ربما هذا ال ال
الايرانيون يستطيعون التصرف بابتكارها
معينه من دخول يمكن ان يكون رابعا لها في
موضوع اغلاق مضيق هرمز ويمكن ان يكون
العكس تماما ممكن ان يكون تعتبر عملا
استفزازيا ومن ثم تتجه الى مناورات تتبعها
بين وقت اخر كان مثلا اوراقها الصغيره
التي اشرت اليها المسلحه ربما تتحرك بهذا
الهدف الجديد في التعبير ليس بغرض اه
التصادم بقدر ما هو شيء من التصعيد
والمناوره فقط
نعم هذا ممكن
في الحقيقه نحن راينا كيف ان ايران اجرت
واخرا عددا من التدريبات العسكريه التي
تزامنت مع تهديدات هم بغلق المضيق وربما
قد يفعلون ذلك ولكن اعتقد اننا بعد كل ما
ذكرنا وكل ما تقدم هذا ليس باعث قلقهم
العسكري الرئيسي اعتقد انهم سيكون اكثر
قلقا من وجود حاملات طائرات اكبر تدخل
وتخرج من منطقه الخليج الولايات المتحده
انا لا اعتقد ان الحرب ستكون محتمله بينها
وبين ايران لكن لا تمر
فانها ستحتاج الولايات المتحده الى
الاعتماد على الهجمات الجويه بالطائرات
بشكل هجمات مكثفه كبيره لكن لا هذا مثل
هذه السفينه ليست مهيئه لذلك هي مهيئه
لعمليات
سريعه مثل تلك التي تمت ال اسامه بن لادن
او انقاذ رهائن لذلك ربما يجب ان لا تشكل
هذه السفينه تهديدا لايران من الناحيه
الاجواء ايضا هي مهيئه للتصدي للالغام
وهذا اه عنصر اساسي في اه عملها اريد ان
اسالك دكتور مصطفى العاني لكن تريد ان
تعلق على موضوع ايران اكثر ولكن ربما اه
يعني ركزنا كثيرا على ايران واه لم نتحدث
عن موضوع اليمن بما يكفي اه هناك اشاره لا
ادري اذا كانت تستحق التوقف عندها ولكن اه
اه نجل الرئيس اليمني
علي عبد الله صالح قال انه هو مستعد
للتخلي عن منصبه اه لانه اه
تولى منصب قيادي في قوات متعدده الجنسيه
لمكافحه الارهاب عبر الحدود في منطقه
الشرق الاوسط تشرف عليها الولايات المتحده
هل يمكن ان يكون لهذه القاعده العائمه اي
علاقه بهذه التصريحات التي سربت
اه
لها عده اهداف اولا هناك يجب عدم المبالغه
ب اه ماذا
تقوم هذه القاعده بالاضافه اه الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تمتلك ثلاثه اه حامله
الطائرات في منطقه الشرق الاوسط اثنان
منها بشكل مستمر في منطقه الخليج وبحر
العرب ونحن نتكلم عن حامله طائرات نحن
نتكلم عن مجموعه قتاليه
نتكلم عن سبعه عشر سفينه مع جمع كل حامله
الطائره هناك قاعده كبيره كبيره في
البحرين قاعده بحريه الاسطول الخامس هناك
قاعده جويه كبيره في في اه في
وقياده كامله هناك قاعده في في اه الكويت
هذا نحن نتكلم عن نوع جديد وهو قوات
التدخل السريع الدكتور قوات تدخل سريع
ستقوم ب مهمات محدده وهي مهمات مكافحه
الارهاب مكافحه القرصنه ومكافحه مو قضيه
منع اه اه اه وضع الغام في اه اه اه في
منطقه المسجد
هذه القاعده لم تمتلك قوه اكثر من مجموعه
مقاتلين متخصصين زائدا طائرات هليكوبتر لا
تمتلك الثامن هذا القاضي انه هذا يجب ان
نضع هذا في في في اطار ها الشيء الثاني
هناك مبالغه رهيبه في قوه ايران هناك
مبالغه ايرانيه وهناك مبالغه غربيه بقوه
ايران ايران توافق نفسها عسكريا بدون اي
مبرر وهذا ما وجدنا اه السيناريو العراقي
والسيناريو الليل عندما قاموا بعمليه
الاتفاق الذاتي فانا باعتقادي ان هناك
مبالغه كبيره ان كان قضيه مكافحه الارهاب
بدون شك هذه تشكل جزء اساسي الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه تقف في من مشكله اساسيه
بعدم وجود القاعده لمكافحه الارهاب قاعده
عسكريه لمكافحه الارهاب في المنطقه التي
تستخدم جيبوتي بخير يا القيام بغارات في
داخل اه اه اليمن الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه قامت خلال السنوات الماضيه سته
عشر عمليه اغتيال وعمليه هجوم داخل اليمن
واليمن كانت متعاونه النظام اليمني كان
متعاون بشكل كامل مع الولايات المتحده
وهناك اتفاقيه تسمح للولايات المتحده
بالقيام بعمليات في داخل اليمن بالذات
الطائرات بدون طيار لكن بيت
كل شخص اجنبي يراس هذه المجموعه هذه
المجموعه موجوده وبالذات موجوده على على
بوسائل الجو يعني انا ما اتكلم على الارض
هناك تعاون نعم ولكن اي اجد من الصعب جدا
ان تقوم الولايات المتحده بتعيين شخص
اجنبي برغم خبرته في هذا المنصب الحساس و
هذا المنصب الذي يحتاج الى معلومات
مخابراتيه مهمه والمشكله التي واجهتها
الولايات المتحده مع الباكستان هي تسريب
المعلومات المخابراتيه في مكافحه الارهاب
لهذا قامت بعمليه اغتيال اسامه بن لادن
بدون اخبار الباكستانيين فهي لن تقوم
بمشاركه هذه العمليات الخاصه تقوم على
عمليات مخابراتيه دقيقه اولا ان لم يكن
هناك معلومات مخابراتيه دقيقه لم تقم هذه
العمليات المعلومات المخابرات في الدقيقه
لا تقوم الولايات المتحده بالمشاركه مع اي
دوله واي جهه اخرى اشكرك دكتور مصطفى
العاني مدير قسم الابحاث الامنيه
والدفاعيه في مركز الخليج للابحاث واشكرك
ال مدير المركز التحليلات السياسيه
والعسكريه في معهد هدفا من واشنطن وشكرا
لكم مشاهينا الكرام على متابعه هذه الحلقه
من البرنامج
ام